let me just hanging on
oh everyone wants a pick with the
Maverick good morning aviators
yes Tom was sworn by all the stars at
the 95th Oscar's luncheon
tough gun Maverick may have scored six
Oscar nominations including best motion
picture but it's Tom who's winning the
popular vote even everything everywhere
all at one star kiwi Kwan is letting his
inner Fanboy shine
[Music]
Tom is also taking Jamie Lee Curtis's
breath away with a big squeeze and smile
and even Austin Butler was Starstruck
are you ready to fly how much ready to
fly good to meet Tom Cruise for the
first time that's that's very surreal
yeah it's the king of rock and roll and
the MAV finally meet I just I think of
all the times that I've watched his
performances and
um it's it's really surreal when you
finally in the presence of somebody that
you've watched for so many years you
know as for the class photo Tom Cruise
cozied up to another nominee Angela
Bassett
for her role in Black Panther wakanda
forever Angela urges people to broaden
their Horizons in film see an array of
movies whether you think you can relate
to it or not or it looks like you or not
well it's easy and it's possible to to
miss very very fine performances but
frame of reference is everything so have
a wide and open frame of deafness and
the star power doesn't stop there also
on the lunch and carpet Kate Blanchett
Colin Farrell and Brandon Frazier who's
looking happy as ever in the Oscar class
photo